hello and welcome back to steampunks the
gate spot show we go back through the
last seven days of steam your laces and
pick out our favorite titles to
recommend we do to you I'm Edmund Tran
I'm just what he's been playing this
week all righty so one of the games I
was playing this week is called Gollum
yeah this is not to be confused with the
ps4 game gone which was showed off a
couple of years ago at e3 from high wire
this one is from longbow games so this
is a really lovely looking puzzle game
where you and your goal and companion
work your way through various levels of
a massive tower and you basically
leverage your respective abilities to
get to the end of each level you path
your way through each level so you're
actually point and clicking your way
around not wasting your way around and
thankfully you can hold space to speed
up as you've got to traverse pretty far
these levels are huge and moving with
the golem especially early on in his
earlier iterations is kind of a slow
process the levels are really beautiful
a very journey ask and the accompanying
music is also really lovely the
point-and-click elements extends to
climbing ropes using your cursor to draw
shapes in the air while you're moving
platforms or switching levers back and
forth and clicking on items to interact
with including clicking on your golem to
interact with them you'll encounter
these pools of mysterious glowing blue
light which change your golem into
different kind of versions of himself
sort of like it reminds me of that xbox
game that nobody played recall yeah it
reminds me of Rico so it's kind of that
same thing where it's like still your
golden buddy but he seems transferring
to different variations even if you are
a puzzle fan as the levels are just so
expansive that it can be rough to get
your head around originally but as you'd
expect the Golem becomes way more of a
help than a hindrance and it also
changes your approach to puzzles which
makes it much more interesting because
its capabilities change so the way
you're thinking your your way around
each level needs to change occasionally
there's issues with the camera angle
because you can miss things or
misunderstand where you can and can't
pass through as either character there's
also a little bit of a
lack of a sense of what you're supposed
to be doing and why like any puzzle game
you get the point that you're supposed
to be interacting with things and trying
to move forward the game so far seems to
be about the growing fondness between
the two characters more than anything
else and there are some really nice
moments there the story could also
develop as the game goes on and I just
haven't encountered that yet the lovely
thing about these sprawling levels is
when you do hit that aha moment of a
puzzle game when you finally solve
something that seems impenetrable it's
incredibly satisfying if you're a fan of
environmental puzzle games you should
have a really good time with this one
and it's only 15 dollars so if you like
these kind of games I would get on board
it's fun time
well the game I played had gold in it
too except I was killing them and
selling their calls for money that's
depressing a game I played okay go on
yes this game's called it a moonlighter
so this is a top-down 2d Zelda style
roguelike where you play the role of
both a hero and an NPC style merchant so
the story here is that it was like a
randomly generating dungeon that
sprouted up out of nowhere and a town
spreaded up around it with merchants to
supply the heroes with goods so they go
into the dungeons and do all that kind
of like roguelike stuff unfortunately
the hero started dying a lot and now the
town is suffering and losing a lot of
business you're the last in a line of
family merchants and your stores in
trouble so the game loop is that you are
equipped to go down to the dungeons
yourself and kill enemies together their
materials to sell later
it's got like sort of roguelike thing of
how far do I push myself here and like
how much stuff can I carry with me and
once you think you're at your limit or
your backpack is full you can instantly
teleport back out so once you're out
you'll open up your store put all the
stuff you found on sale for other people
you choose the prices of things that you
want to sell people will come along to
your shop and look at them if the price
is right they'll buy it if it's too
expensive they won't they'll get angry
the game really makes being a merchant
easy because it makes a note of each
customer's reaction to certain numerical
values or sale prices for certain
objects so it's something you'll learn
to feel that as you start going on and
there are like dozens and dozens and
dozens of items another thing is to
think about is like gathering enough
materials to earn enough money to expand
the town again so you'll start inviting
other merchants like blacksmiths and
alchemists to come set up shop and
invest your own money into them to give
them a bit of startup capital and
they'll reward you with the ability to
like make new weapons like make potions
or that kind of stuff too so there's
also a bit of like do I save all this
material that I gather to craft sell for
myself or like suds other people for
money so once you get deeper into the
dungeons and the sort of adventuring
part of the game you'll get this item
called like a mirror it's like a
merchant's mirror where you can sort of
empty your backpack into it and get like
instant money but you don't get a lot of
money out of it the combat is
challenging but pretty basic at least in
a couple of hours that I played and I
wouldn't really call this a hardcore
action game but it is one that requires
really good positioning and timing yeah
there are a number of different dungeons
I've only been playing the first one but
I think there are four or five in total
it's a really nice looking well-rounded
and interesting
package and the merchant stuff adds a
lot of variety to the roguelike sort of
action stuff it's only 20 bucks on Steam
and it's out in every other console as
well so it's while we're taking a look
if you like this kind of game at all
[Music]
all right well I played a game that is
like that game except not at all okay so
it's a dark nods new game vampire
it's vampire we looked it up sir
don't nod if you already know at the
team who made life is strange which I
was really a big fan of this game was
also nothing like that game so vampire
is an action RPG where you play a newly
turned vampire living in London in 1918
you're getting accustomed to your powers
so it makes a lot of sense that you're
leveling naturally and picking up new
skills naturally you'll be taking on
quests fighting for your life as you can
imagine the living are not big fans of
the undead but at the same time you
actually moonlight yes there you go you
moonlight as a doctor so what you can do
when you talk to NPCs is give them
health check-ups and basically heal the
sick although there is a sinister after
that because you can eat any of the
NPC's that's good as in drain them of
blood and get a lot of experience points
so you'll be wrestling with whether or
not to eat the people you get to know
and there's also another interesting
mechanic in that the better you get to
know people the more you find out about
them and talk to them the higher their
blood experience level will rise so the
more you get invested in the NPCs around
you the more you'll be rewarded if you
decide to kill them off you'll get
experience tree doing all kinds of
things like going through investigations
helping out people in the world and
their quests so in the initial gameplay
quest you are searching for your saya
and trying to find out what's happened
to you
at the same time as kind of making holes
on whether or not you want to help or
hurt London which is in a real bad point
it's a post war and flu ravaged there
our quarantine points everywhere it
really feels like an accurate depiction
of what being a vampire would be like
and I realize how strange that sentence
is but you have a health meter a stamina
bar and a blood level meter keeping your
blood up means that you'll be stronger
solving mysteries in the town is also
really cool the characters are really
interesting and built out although
everyone's stupid depressed as far as
combat goes you'll get to equip a
primary and
secondary weapon of your choice they can
be upgraded and there's also a crafting
element where you can make anything from
weaponry to ammunition to healing tonics
I found that combat can be a bit tricky
as you move really quickly but you also
whip around and lose track of where the
enemies are that said you have a lot of
agency to tailor it to your preferred
style as you can choose between a
variety of different weapon types and
abilities you can also employ your
vampire senses to identify weaknesses
and resistances in enemies before you
approach them and that makes things a
lot easier too the voice acting is
generally really good it's a really
gorgeous game to play I think the
character models are really lovely I
think London is paints a really
fascinating world to walk around I find
it really interesting in the way it's so
successful at challenging that light
side I need to be good and bring peace
mentality that I and a lot of other
gamers I know feel like they have
because there is a huge incentive to be
evil now this is a pretty expensive game
it's 50 bucks so far I think it's worth
every dollar I'm having a great time
with it I think it succeeds really well
in all these different genres it's
pulling from and it's got some really
innovative stuff in there too
[Music]
nice
all right well if the world vampire is
too depressing for you then do I have
the cure for you I played a game called
a yoku silent Express and it is a joy to
play okay so this is a 2d platformer
slash Metroidvania crossed with Inbal so
your cusan Express is set on a very
vibrant tropical island and you play as
a little I think it's a dung beetle okay
who's taking over as the postman on the
island which is very nice and this
little guy is as dung beetles do pushes
a little ball around everywhere probably
of his own poop or like someone else's
poop but you know whatever
now you can't jump as a beetle because
you have to push this big ball around to
movement it's pretty basic so you'll be
going left and right but the island is
filled with pinball flippers everywhere
that you control and you can use those
flippers to push yourself into different
paths in the branch of world and also
someone to bigger puzzles in the world
which basically act like full pinball
boards where the goals are very similar
to like an actual pinball game the main
thing that encourages exploration in
this game is that a lot of the flip is
around the island unlocked and to unlock
them you have to collect a bunch of
fruit I really love this game so far
after a couple hours of play the pace is
really great it moves along very very
smoothly I think it also helps that it's
very hard to die taking damage or losing
a ball and a pin more puzzle will make
you lose fruit you can keep usually keep
going right away it's just nice as
health to play it's 20 bucks and it's
also on consoles
all right well that is everything we've
got for you guys this week do let us
know what you thought of this week's
games and if there's anything we should
be keeping an eye out for we will be
taking a break
43 but you can still hit us up on
twitter i am at jess mcdonald madman
trend as always do let us know what you
thought about this week's episode and we
will see you again next time
[Music]
[Music]